salut les gars
m
j'ai tout donné
alors alors alors chez vous parce que
vous allez jouer avec pitchouns on sait
qu est ce que vous avez fait hier avoir
acheté des comédies musicales et on
mettrait hors d'elle toi possible pour
me faut qu à sa tête avait parlé de tout
et c'est humour ou la peste flap est mon
frère chez lui
ils vont faire jouer dans toute l'équipe
à toute la troupe des robins des bois et
je voudrais chanter des comédies
musicales
c'est là votre façon au fait une enquête
ou demander des planches s'était tu vois
tu as chaud là tu veux quoi tu je te
montre la puissance ou quoi que ça
marche partira voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est super
[Applaudissements]
la discorde
je voulais c'est du faux c'est là qu'est
l'os dans la même rejet du ca pour tous
les jours je me bats latine
[Applaudissements]
j'essayais de minutes
heureusement que c'était pas le partant
excuse moi pourtant des défauts se place
alors cassé la gueule m'habitue nos
allées des vasières de la musique c'est
tellement simple l'amour thème
impossible amour qui la regardent autour
à qui le tour
pêcheurs et glamour faudra se donner
tout honneur et mai
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est la bouche c'est quoi envie d'aimer
exactement votre iphone
[Applaudissements]
les voitures en piste au sommet sûr mais
ne fait plus mais il y avait mêlée ne
savent pas qu'on passe à une tomme
bavarois qui s'est nouée roi loi fait
l'amour en vie la vie la vie jour après
jour nuit après nuit après nuit à quoi
ça sert et du raté sur la terre si c'est
pour faire 9e
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce que vous avez trompés